welcome to CBS this morning we'll begin
with this tropical storm Gordon
threatens more than 8 million people
along the Gulf Coast where it's expected
to make landfall there's a hurricane by
later tonight the National Hurricane
Center says top sustained winds are now
65 miles an hour
a hurricane warning is up from the
Louisiana Mississippi border to the
Florida Panhandle
Gordon will bring powerful winds
dangerous storm surge and heavy
downpours maybe as much as 12 inches of
rain from now until Thursday
Omar Villafranca is on the Gulf Coast in
Pascagoula Mississippi where people can
already feel the storm
Omar good morning good morning a few
hundred miles out in the storm is
brewing now the wind is kind of calm
right now we are starting to see a
little bit of chop at this area is under
a hurricane warning and we're expecting
to feel the brunt of this storm later on
in the day as it gets closer to land and
as it intensifies from a tropical storm
to a potentially devastating hurricane
tropical storm Gordon formed over South
Florida on Monday morning
flashing parts of the Sunshine State
with strong winds and pounding rain
beaches that would normally be packed on
the Labor Day holiday like Miami South
Beach were practically empty completely
different from our expectation for this
weekend the heavy rains flooded out some
local roads in Homestead south of Miami
catching some drivers off guard across
the Gulf Coast people are preparing for
the force of Gordon in Biloxi
Mississippi they stocked up on supplies
at the grocery store while the fire
department geared up for possible water
rescues along the Alabama coast
residents who live in communities that
have flooded before are anxious
Louisiana Governor John bel Edwards is
taking no chances issuing an emergency
declaration ahead of the storm making
landfall and mobilizing 200 National
Guardsmen these Guardsmen will be
pre-positioned primarily in Southeast
Louisiana
along with 63 high water vehicles 39
boats and four helicopters with memories
of Katrina still lingering in new
Orleans officials issued a voluntary
evacuation orders for areas outside the
city's levee protection system
but Mayor Latoya Cantrell says they are
prepared we've got the pumps in power we
believe we need again to be safe and
protect our residents Gordon could be a
category 1 hurricane by the time it
makes landfall and of course the big
concern with hurricanes is the storm
surge and officials with the National
Hurricane Center say they're expecting
anywhere from 3 to 5 feet with this
storm surge and that on the coastal area
can cause millions of dollars in damage
John O'Mara thank you those are some
ominous clouds behind you